tanguy de lamotte louis burton éric
bellion c3 yvelinois parti s'y prend la
8ème édition du vendée globe et skippers
s'élanceront des sables d'olonne le 6
novembre prochain pour ce tour du monde
en solitaire et sans escale jamais
autant divinement elle avait participé à
la compétition
la mère a pas de frontières et on n'a
pas besoin d'être né
près de la mer pour pour rêver à la mer
moi quand j'étais petit à versailles
j'étais sous la couette avec mes
bouquins de mer je rêvais de mer et j'ai
découvert la mer à l'adolescence et
depuis j'ai pas lâché et je crois qu'on
est beaucoup dans mon cas je suis pas du
tout un cas isolé il ya beaucoup de
divine oies qui pensent qu'ils pensent à
la mer qui rêvent de la mer les trois
événements des objectifs une expérience
différente sur l'épreuve tanguy de
lamotte participera pour la deuxième
fois la compétition en 2013 le verset y
avait terminé à la 10e place
premier objectif ça c'est une évidence
c'est de réussir à boucler ce challenge
de repères le tour du monde le deuxième
objectif c'est mon objectif sportif on
va dire donc d'essayer de faire le tour
du monde le plus vite possible et avec
ce bateau là ça serait de faire le tour
du monde en 80 jours
donc c'est un objectif aussi assez
symbolique éric bellion seraient nos
vies sur cette course mythique après sa
septième place sur la transat jacques
vabre en 2015 le versailles et
s'attaquer ce tour du monde pour la
première fois c'est vraiment à l'arrivée
il me regarder dans la glace et de me
dire tu as bien assurer ta fête a fait
une belle course tu as donné tout ce que
tu avais
tu es allé au bout de toi même tu est
elle est là où tu pensais pas aller et
est un rendu les gens heureux est
apporté ton message de plus loin
possible
louis burton de son côté tentera cette
fois ci de terminer la course après
avoir abandonné en 2012 50 % de la
flotte qui abandonnent chaque édition
c'est un peu la statistique
ce qui prouve que il peut vraiment se
passer plein de trucs les moyens
modernes
ne permettent pas de deux
limiter cette case d'empêcher les
abandons j'ai pas pu terminer la
dernière fois donc j'espère bien que
cette fois ci ça pourra le faire et que
la malchance sera ailleurs les skippers
et binoy succéderont peut-être à
françois gabart vainqueur de l'épreuve
en 2013 en 78 jours record du vendée
globe